hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to dpo or die epi oh where
I'm not 100% sure what it's called
because I don't get any of the names of
these games correctly considering agario
& Schley very Oh aren't the actual names
of those games but I'm gonna call dpo
cuz I got nothing else to do with my
life and this game has been unbelievably
like unbelievably requested every single
mg fibers crawling up my ass already
every single social media that I have
has been inundated with requests for
this game and so this game is actually
relatively simple but in the same agario
and slippery OH stylings you're
basically on a grid and your little dude
and amongst a sea of other dudes but in
this one it's different because you're a
tank in this one and it's got a really
interesting upgrade system where you're
trying to kill both other players and
these boxes here which I don't know what
they represent other than just like
normal resources that you have to blow
up I'm assuming this is America
simulator because you got to blow up
everything's to progress in the world
there's other players and as you upgrade
throughout the game you get various
different branching options with which
you can play the game like right now I
just got the basic stuff and I'm gonna
upgrade a bullet damage and speed if you
notice in the bottom left you got a lot
of upgrades options over there and the
various size shapes and color crap there
various different amounts of points to
get by and the quicker you get points
you can more you level up blah blah blah
but what the more important thing is
that when you get to about level what do
you do about level 20 yeah there's some
higher level people that are creeping
around it you get you gotta play it safe
and try not to bother anybody before you
just die a horrible death
god Dolan don't do it I won't mess with
you you all miss me come on you can also
shoot oh [ __ ] me oh god let me get my
health up oh god I'm gonna die see okay
but if you see over here I now have twin
guns and I'm going with twin guns
because before I tried the machine gun
path and then I got to this cannon thing
that didn't work out too well for me it
did make me go pretty fast around but
that's getting too deep into the
stratagems about this game instead of
getting to something that I could
actually control what just
Oh anyway oh I'm so sorry Arielle you
have to oh you're you're you're not here
you were your you were spawning I guess
and I was trying to kill you like an
idiot as you get your upgrades going
you'll notice that your guns shoot much
better more and do the thing better and
this was actually pretty good hot damn
it's like the machine gun but I got two
barrels it's even better than the
machine gun that I had before right
right for upgrades I'm double dick Rick
blasted my way through DP oh I don't
know I don't know what it's called why's
that guy just named well he's dead
exactly ask alright a way so now that I
got my bullet damage and reload up I'm
going to be hopefully upgrading some
more stuff and not dying a horrible
death that would be ideal
that guy's machine gunner oh I'm
surrounded by death
I'm surrounded by every type of death
thank you little guy that little guy was
trying to be advantageous about a
circumstance but it worked out for me
better than worked out for him it's just
so easy to die in this game but what's
good about is that when you do die you
actually spawn again at half you're the
holy [ __ ] that guy yeah that guy I got
to get my bullet speed up because I'm
not able to chase anybody down with my
bullet sir it's it's a really effective
deterrent just to blast someone with a
spray of bullets the like the wits
they've never seen for babsy boo got
blasted off art and then on this
leaderboard man link is way to high
score but the other good thing is
there's a max level that you can reach
so there's sort of like a a limit to how
far you can progress so that makes it so
that some people aren't just absolutely
unbeatable and also I've noticed that
the more bullets you shoot the slower
you go you know I'm at some a bruh oh
yeah hi guys why are you shooting so
slow what's wrong with that guy I don't
know everything probably he's probably
just luring me in with a false sense of
security before he annihilated me well I
seem to be annihilating him so I'm gonna
leave him alone for now maybe we're
buddies maybe maybe maybe baby we're
buddies I have no idea oh yeah okay so
I'm gonna get my movement speed up
because I need to be able to dodge oh
it's you it's you know Sony yucks come
here baby
he's got way more faster speed than I
but if you shoot in the opposite
direction the lights to go faster which
is kind of
interesting stratagem because allows you
to both run away from the people that
you're trying to not die from and then
also it allows you to kind of weirdly
push yourselves toward people if you
fire in the opposite direction it's very
bizarre and like combination of
different elements coming together it's
kind of a nice little bit of what you
might call strategy but I don't have
none to that no Simon
you're cool in my book let's just take
the little little baby tanks that we
just murdered and take their points and
run away forever and ever
never again oh good I imagine this one's
also gonna get mobbed soon to get sound
effects and whatnot I I feel like this
one needs a bit more stressful sound
effects or at least epic battle music
going on because you're actually a tank
that's blowing [ __ ] mmm I can be triple
triple strong John I could be triple
penis eNOS I'm gonna be triple penis
eNOS
oh is this better it's better I liked it
better before I could actually
concentrate the things that I was
shooting at this this is sometimes like
this is what happened before while I was
doing the machine gun and the machine
gun was gone I'm so slow my shoes this
wagon I could like Street sweep the
items that's good I'll get a lot of
points that way I wasn't gonna get a lot
of points from killing anybody anyway so
why would I bother with anything else
all right so I got three upgrades I'm
just kind of sorry excuse my spray
everybody excuse the spray from Triple P
no Xena's coming I just want to be a
wall of death anything that approaches
me rapidly rethinks it's choices in life
that's that's the only thing that I want
it's the only thing that I need also you
can see I'm just passing the leader on
the left there he's going over there
there is a battle going on here I'm just
trying to shoot the bullets coming my
way it's actually a pretty effective
deterrent I mean if no one sneaks up
behind me and stabs me in the butt I
think I'll be relatively okay but I
actually I actually liked this game a
lot it allows for a lot of strategy and
individual play
is good Tokyo ghoul or you just you just
is he is he just well but I got him
guess I've got a lot of ports out of
that he was just sitting around waiting
for death that's the only thing that I
need in my life just people to take
advantage of before the end
okay I need last bit of bullet damage
I'm gonna max my health out some tough
is rock and then I believe there's only
five levels after this so I probably
gonna max out movement speed and then
hope for the best from there cuz link is
still top dog on the leaderboard baby
yeah I'm on the leaderboard I'm only
number ten but I'm okay that's okay in
my book I'm just gonna get away from
this leader if I just shoot backwards
I'm totally ok I go super fast
no one mind me if I just create like a
box it's really fun because every person
is their own bullet-hell like it's just
a non-stop bullet hell of various
players going about and then they're
just having fun trying to dodge
everybody's bullets it works out quite
nicely I think that guy's a sniper Oh
ranked oh I've played many a rake games
if you don't wanna mess with me because
thinking about this is my bullets do so
much damage that they actually knock
other people's bullets out of the air
competition is getting kind of fierce I
need I need these I I need these items
for stuff and the things I didn't see
one time whoa whoa whoa ow ow ow ow
Jesus who was that the market Farkle is
the mark of art lives on oh my god what
is with that guy holy [ __ ]
when do I get an upgrade like that I'm
just stuck on a triple penis eNOS I want
to be back to double dick Rick maybe
even more dongs more dongs alike I don't
know oh god this bad situation bad
situation bad situation oh my god
someone's a good shot not this guy
obviously back up backwards I've got so
much to live for
I've got so many things to do with my
triple penis I've got no health regen I
was stupid I made bad choices I tried to
be master of a few instead of Master of
Allah
oh just run away just beware my spray Oh
God that is too many bullets that's an
unfair amount of bullets that is
literally way too many bullets I went to
the competition area I didn't even
realize that I was oh god I I'm gonna
get health regen but it's not gonna do
me any good mmm
dad dad would dad would daddy dodge Oh
dad's a large yes yeah pick on the
little guys and dodge the little guys Oh
fuck-you sniper boy brett-brett you want
to come at me Britt
you wanna come okay we're fine
everything is totally good no no don't
do it Marvin Marvin Marvin Marvin Marvin
Marvin come on come on Marvin come on
come on please
they'll be this way they'll be this way
Marv Oh God who's doing that
[ __ ] yeah I just gotta get at it so the
good thing about when you dies that you
actually spawn in half your level so
you're not just totally done and
actually if you get high enough you can
actually start at a rank who I need to
get up quick okay reload I'm gonna go
for movement speed this time and then
health regen I'm gonna go I'm gonna go
twin again but I'm not gonna go triple
penis eNOS because that was just it was
just it was it was too much to handle I
can't I can't handle all that
responsibility if you know what I mean
you don't know I mean okay well just
like you I'll keep blaspheming over here
in the corner don't mind me
hit me it's a let's play corner up in
the top left don't worry about it's
totally cool what did I not upgrade my
bullet damage at all really did I not do
that I must not have upgraded my I did
not upgrade my damage at all why didn't
I do that that was like it's super
important for me to upgrade cuz I can't
actually get any points out of it if I
can't kill anything
well I'm fast so I guess does
consolation prizes are cool too or you
know passage ish everyone's going for
twin Gunners apparently early that's the
you've activated my trap card the thing
I don't do much damage really that would
have been dangerous for you Oh what are
you gonna do huh oh he let me he had
body damage oh [ __ ]
oh god oh [ __ ] I guess start over at the
beginning again okay I'm just gonna go
damage and reload cuz [ __ ] it [ __ ] this
sounds so good I'm ending so terribly
I'm going down in flames I don't have
any sassy jokes to save me from this oh
man oh my god oh [ __ ] hi I had at night
I didn't have it I lost it I went for I
the the moral this story has never go
for triple penis eNOS it'll never work
out for you it's it's not worth the risk
if you know what I mean alright I'm
gonna go for sniper cuz why not oh yes
this is good I like that
oh nice and slow oh but I can see more
so that's good I mean I guess oh [ __ ]
hello weak little market not the market
[ __ ] one more oh sweet delicious life
that's right back off you can't beat me
well you probably could have you
depressed your advantage but you won't
be pressing nothing against me snipers
actually pretty cool I will admit
snipers actually not bad snipers not the
worst I've ever seen his sniper allows
me to one see more and to make precision
strikes so if I'm good at what I do
which I'm not I can get some kills which
I won't
that's an interesting strategy though
going for body damage because people
probably wouldn't see it coming if you
got enough bullets to block their
bullets but just to get closer and a lot
of movement speed you can probably do a
lot of damage to someone and they would
never know what will hit him like like
like what happened to me I never even
thought about that as a strategy
like melee classic in DP oh you don't
wanna mess with me bruh you know what
amazed me
[ __ ] I don't wanna mess with him
okay alright that's all the time I got
for this episode of deep you I'm gonna
start out on a new server and hopefully
it'll work out better for me because I
had it in the beginning I did I
performed high in the beginning and then
I just sailed downwards into the depths
of stupidity which is where I usually
end up in all my let's play so thank you
everybody so much for watching you can
play this game for yourself in the
comments in the description below
there's a link down there it's really
fun totally free like the other ones and
just an enjoyable time so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you
[Music]
what a bunch of bull ass